it's time for CBS morning's deals where
we share some items that could make your
life a little bit easier all that
exclusive low prices this week we're
highlighting some of our most popular
deals and they might just become
Essentials in your everyday life to
start shopping go ahead and scan that QR
code on your screen right now you can
also visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle Elizabeth uh
lifestyle expert Elizabeth Warner is
joining us right now let's start this
thing off so what do we have here yes so
excited so yes all the best of the best
this one everyone fell in love with this
is the UV now I'm going to show you I've
got it on my app here on my phone I'm
going to hit on and it's instantly going
to start to move and do the cleaning for
us so now I have more time for my
husband my kids going for a walk
whatever I want to do I come home the
house is clean HEPA filter it's got
great built-in technology that's
actually going to get rid of the Dust
the dander the pet hair all of that
stuff even viruses and bacteria you can
also add oil into this and put a
beautiful Aroma yeah so great so this
normally is 3.99 today a 200 savings so
down to 199. 50 off let it do the
cleaning work for you okay the next one
I remember this it was very loud so we
should give it a little bit it's very
loud yes so this is she's birdie and
it's a personal device alarm just like
we would have for our home you open a
door it sets an alarm off to protect
your goods well we want to protect our
children our grandchildren our nieces my
daughters are both on college campus
protect ourselves ourselves so if you
feel something feel strange it is
strange you can pull this out now I'm
going to pull it it's really loud so I'm
just giving you a little warning but
it's got a 130 decibel alarm plus a
flashing light so this will deter people
if you feel that something funny in your
gut you have to go with it so this is
she's birdie normally
29.95 today 40 off so just 17.97 my
girls carry this everywhere they go
college campus easy to carry for all of
us easy to carry comes with a brass
keychain throw it in your colors and
bright colors I love yes all right
heating pad but it does more than just
heat yes so it's a calming massaging
heat pad so not only does this have heat
it's not just like our mom's heating pad
it's got clay beads in it I'm going to
let you feel that so it's actually
weighted but the best part is the
massage feature so when you turn this on
not only do you have three different
ways of heat but six different massage
patterns oh wow so it vibrates it's warm
it's relaxing think of all the people
you know sitting at a desk all day
you're standing on your feet you can
just turn this on throw it on you on the
couch on your office chair wherever you
might be yes there is relaxing and
amazing so calming heat normally
64.99 today 50 off so just 32.50 that's
a deal right this is where it's at comfy
and delicious uh so we should send a
bunch of these to Florida Elizabeth I
was going to say so yes jump start yes
and again these are all the hottest
items we brought you so far on our CBS
deals this one by far is the most
essential it should be in everyone's car
this jump smart can not only jump start
your car it comes with these amazing
cables but in addition to being able to
jump start your car 30 plus times it's
annoying because it's buzzing because we
can hear it we'll turn it right off of
there there we go oh there we go start
your car but your SUV yeah I mean it
makes me want to take a nap yeah but not
only that but we can undo the back of
this it's got a dual charger in here so
we can charge it that's everything vices
yes flashlight alarm so car home bring
it home and my daughter down in the
hurricane and Ian down in Florida I said
to her bring it into your dorm keep it
with you so you have a flashlight you
have the alarm if you need it the
charging device as well it's it's got a
compass on the back it's got a
thermometer it's cold in here yeah yes
every it is a little chilly everything
you can imagine so normally
139.99 sale price 79.99 that's 43 off it
flashes I think that's awesome
absolutely indoors every car thank you
so much and of course we partner with
all of these companies to get these
incredible deals to buy anything that
you saw scan the QR code on your screen
right now or you can head over to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we
have everything you need and more we'll
be right back so